este inusual gesto eclipsó la clausura
del vigésimo congreso del partido
comunista de China el ex presidente
hugging Tao de 79 años fue desalojado de
la sala tras un breve forcejeo poco
antes de las votaciones del partido y
ante la impasividad del actual
mandatario el partido no ha dado ninguna
explicación de la aparente purga pública
o de si se trató de problemas de salud
se ha logrado el propósito de unificar
pensamientos fortalecer la confianza
aclarar la dirección e inspirar el
espíritu de lucha Esta es una
conferencia para mantener en alto la
bandera reunir fuerzas y avanzar en la
unidad
después de siete días de reuniones el
líder chino sale fortalecido gracias a
las nuevas enmiendas a la Constitución
destinadas a consolidar el estatus
central de Pin por al menos otros cinco
años entre los cambios de sus estatutos
estaba la referencia explícita al freno
de la independencia de Taiwán y la
inclusión del concepto espíritu de lucha
donde el reitera que es partidario de la
unidad específicamente de la
reunificación pacífica con Taiwán pero
que él estaría dispuesto a utilizar el
uso de la fuerza él tiene como ejemplo
pues lo que ha sucedido entre Ucrania y
Rusia y no quiere cometer esos errores y
él dice que efectivamente Esto hace
parte de que se tiene que resolver de
una forma pacífica entonces lo que
estamos viendo Es que él busca que el
pueblo chino sea el que tome la decisión
y no haya injerencia internacional el
congreso también confirmó la elección de
205 miembros del Congreso central con la
re veteranos como el Primer Ministro
liquexiaong y el vicepre Primer Ministro
wangyang este domingo se conocerá
Quiénes son los siete miembros del
poderoso comité permanente pero parece
que el máximo órgano del partido estará
compuesto en su mayoría por chistas